- The single reason I woke
up today and have not,
and don't do weekend events,
'cause that's my family time,
I woke up this morning and got here today
was to tell you one thing.
Which is, I recommend it very seriously
that you go home and think about the fact
that you should probably allocate
the next three to four years of your life
to try to execute on the
thing that you want to do
for the fucking rest of your life.
If you really want to do
the thing that drives you,
that's when you get into the zone of like,
"Cool, I don't need to
live in the best place."
"Cool, I'll commute from
a little further away."
"Cool, I'll team up
with four or five people
and sleep on a couch."
And I think that that to me
is the part that's most interesting.
The reason I'm willing to trade
is because I know how awesome it feels
to do what you love.
It's what I've been able
to do my whole life.
(techno music)